thank you thank you thank you for that
introduction but first I should say a
few few words by Who I am and what on
earth I'm doing up here
my name is Bonner and I am a rock star
not as a boast but but more as a kind of
confession because in my view the only
thing worse than a rock star is a rock
star with a conscience a celebrity with
a cause oh dear oh dear but worse yet is
a singer with a conscience a placard
waving knee jerking fellow traveling
activist with Alexis and a swimming pool
shaped like his head I'm a singer you
know what a singer is a singer is
someone with a hole in his heart almost
the size of his ego when you need 20,000
people screaming your name in order to
feel good about your day you know you're
a singer
I'm a singer I'm a songwriter I'm also a
father four times over just last week I
am a friend to dogs a sworn enemy of the
saccharin and a believer in grace over
karma I talked too much when I'm drunk
and sometimes even when I'm not I am not
drunk right now these are not sunglasses
these are protection but I must tell you
I own more than my spoiled lifestyle to
rock music I own my world view music was
like an alarm clock for me as a teenager
and still keeps me awake from falling
asleep in the comfort of my freedom rock
music to me is rebel music but rebelling
against what in the 50s it was sexual
mores and double standards in the 60s it
was the Vietnam War and racial and
social inequality what are we rebelling
against now if I'm honest I'm rebelling
against my own indifference I'm
rebelling against the idea that the
world is the way the world is and
there's not a damn thing I can do about
it so I'm trying to do a damn thing but
fighting my indifference is my own
problem what's your problem what's the
hole in your heart
I needed the noise the applause you
needed the grades why are you here in
Harvard Square why do you have to listen
to me
what have you given up to get here is
success your drug of choice or are you
driven by another curiosity your
potential the potential of a given
situation is missing the moment
unacceptable to you is wasting
inspiration a crime to you it is for a
musician
if this is where we find that our lives
rhyme if this is our common ground well
then I can be inspired as well as
humbled to be on this great campus
because that's where I come from music
but I've seen the other side of music
the business I've seen success as a drug
of choice I've seen great minds and
prolific imaginations to disappear up
their own ass strung out on their own
self-importance I'm one of them I've
seen the misery of having it all your
own way the loneliness of sitting at a
table or everybody works for you the
emptiness of arriving at Aspen on a
Gulfstream to stay in your winter pop oh
hold on that's a different speech you
know what I'm talking about but you've
got to keep asking yourself why are you
doing this you've got to keep checking
your motives success from my group u2
has been a lot easier to conjure than
say relevance relevance in the world
relevance in the culture that's
difficult and of course failure is not
such a bad thing it's not a word that
many of you know I'm sure it's what you
fear the most actually but from an
artist point of view failure is where
you get your best material so fighting
indifference versus making a difference
let me tell you a few things you haven't
heard about me even on the Internet hmm
let me tell you how I enrolled at
Harvard and slept with an economics
professor that's right I became a
student at Harvard recently and I came
to work with Professor Jeffrey Sachs at
CID to study the lack of development the
lack of development in third world
economies due to the crushing weight of
old debts those economies were carrying
for generations you see it turns out
that the normal rules of bankruptcy
don't apply to sovereign states it would
be harder for you to get a student loan
and it was for the likes of president
Mobutu to stream billions of dollars
into his Swiss bank account while his
people starved on the side of the road
two generations later the Congolese are
still paying the debts of the fathers
are now the deaths of the sons and the
daughters so here I was representing a
group that believed all such deaths
should be canceled in the year 2000 we
called a jubilee 2000 a fresh start for
a new millennium yeah
it was headed up by an Pettifer based
out of London with huge support from
Africa and the South with Muhammad Ali
Sir Bob Geldof and myself acting at
first just as mouthpieces it was taking
off but we were way behind in the u.s.
we had the melody line so to speak but
in order to get it on the radio over
here we needed a lot of help my friend
Bobby Shriver she guessed it I knock on
the good professors door and a funny
thing happened Jeffrey Sachs not only
let me into his office he let me into
his rolodex his head and his life for
the last few years so in a sense he let
me into your life
here at Harvard a student voila
again I was three weeks in the college
before this all right
so then Sachs and I with my friend Bobby
Shriver hit the road like some sort of
surreal crossover act a rock star a
Kennedy a noted economist criss crossing
the globe like The Partridge Family on
psychotropic drugs we had we had the
Pope acting as our kind of agent we had
the blessing of various rabbis
evangelists mothers unions trade unions
and PTAs it was a new level of unhip for
me but it was very cool it was in that
capacity that I slept with Jeff Sachs
each of us in our own seat on an economy
flight to somewhere passed out like a
couple of drunks but from sheer
exhaustion it was confusing for everyone
I looked up with one eye to see your
hero stubble in all the wrong places his
tie looking like a headband an air
hostess asked if he were a member of the
Grateful Dead
it's more of a moptop situation today I
think you're the groom anyway I have
enormous respect for Jeff Sachs but it's
really true what they say students
should never sleep with their professors
so while I'm handing our trade secrets I
also want to tell you that Larry Summers
your incoming president the man whose
signature is on every American dollar
well he too is a nutcase and a freak you
two made it big out of Boston not New
York not LA so I thought if anyone would
know about our existence it would be a
Treasury secretary from Harvard no when
I said I was from you too he had a
flashback from Cuba in 1962 okay how can
I put this and don't hold it against him
mr. summers is as President Clinton
confirmed to me last week in Dublin
culturally challenged
but when I asked him to look up from the
numbers to see what we were talking
about he did more than that he did the
hardest thing of all for an economist he
saw through the numbers and if it was
hard for me to enlist Larry Summers in
our efforts imagine how hard it was for
Larry Summers to get the rest of
Washington to cough up the cash to
really make a difference for the third
of the world that lives on less than a
dollar a day well he more than tried he
was passionate he turned up in the
offices of his adversary's he turned up
in restaurants with me a rock star to
meet the concerns of his Republican
counterparts counterparts contra parts
that's scary there is a posh restaurant
in Washington or they will not let us in
now such was the heat of his debase
blood on the walls wine in the vinegar
if you're called up before the new
president of Harvard and he gives you
the hairy eyeball drums his fingers and
generally acts disinterested let me tell
you it could be the beginning of a great
adventure for you it's a good thing I
got here before president Rudin Stein
hands over anyway it's a it is at this
point I have to ask if your families
haven't already why am I telling you
these stories it's certainly not because
I'm running for role model I'm telling
you these stories because all the fun
that I had with Jeffrey Sachs and Larry
Summers was in the service of something
deadly serious when people around the
world hear about the burden of debt that
crushes the poorest countries when they
hear that for every dollar of government
aid we send to developing nations nine
dollars comes back to us in debt service
did you hear that for every $1 in
government aid we send to these nations
we receive nine in death service or
payments when people hear that they get
angry
in fact they more than got angry they
took to the streets in what was without
doubt the largest grassroots movement
since the campaign to end apartheid
politics as you know is normally the art
of the possible but this was something
more interesting this was becoming the
art of the impossible we had priests
going into pulpits we had pop stars
going into Parliament's the Pope put on
my sunglasses for a photo session never
released by the way the Vatican didn't
have the same sense of humor as the
pontiff but he was cool
yep we had the Pope putting on
sunglasses we had the religious right
acting like student protesters and
finally after a floor fight in the House
of Representatives we got the money for
3-5 million and more importantly because
this is starting to add up to a lot of
money more importantly this leveraged
billions of dollars from other rich
countries for 3/5
so where did that money go well so far
23 of the poorest countries on the
planet have managed to meet the
sometimes over stringent conditions to
get their debt payments reduced and to
spend the money on the people who need
it most
in Uganda twice as many kids are now
going to school that's good in
Mozambique debt payments are down 42%
allowing health spending to increase by
14 million dollars that's good 14
million dollars goes a long way in
Mozambique to make it more sort of real
just one little story about a remarkable
man in rural Uganda his doctor doctor
Kabira in 1999 measles a disease that's
almost unheard of in the u.s. killed
hundreds of kids in dr. kuvira's
district now thanks to debt relief he's
got an additional six thousand dollars
from the state enough for him to employ
two new nurses and buy two new bicycles
so that they can get around the district
and immunize the children last year
measles was a killer this year dr.
Kabira saw less than 10 cases that's
good
you just wanted you to know what we
pulled off with the help of Harvard with
the help of people like Jeffrey Sachs
sitting right there I'm not here to brag
not to take credit or even to share it
actually or not just to say thanks I
think I've come here for another reason
I think I've come here to ask your help
because this is a big problem and we
need some smart people working on it I
think this will be the defining moment
of our age when the history books but
some of you will write make records of
this moment in time we will be
remembered for two things the internet
probably and the everyday Holocaust that
is Africa 25 million HIV positives who
will leave behind 40 million AIDS
orphans by 2010 in the sub-saharan
Africa alone this is the biggest health
threat since the bubonic plague wiped
out a third of Europe this is happening
right now in our time it's an
unsustainable problem for Africa and
unless we hermetically seal the
continent and close our conscience it's
an unsustainable problem for the world
but it's hard to make this a popular
cause it's hard to make it pop you know
and I guess that's what my job is cuz
pop is often sadly often the oxygen of
politics didn't John and Robert Kennedy
come to Harvard isn't equality a son of
a [ __ ] to follow through on isn't love
thy neighbor in the global village so
inconvenient God writes us these lines
but we have to sing them take them to
the top of the charts but it's not what
the radio is playing isn't it I know I
know
but we've got to follow through on our
ideals or we betray something at the
heart of who we are outside these gates
and even within them the culture of
idealism is under siege beset by
materialism and narcissism and all the
other isms of indifference and their
defense mechanisms knowingness the smirk
the joke we're still idealism has been
reduced to a marketing tool they've got
Martin Luther King selling phones now
have you seen that telecommunications at
Martin Luther King civil rights in
America in Europe are banned to human
rights in the rest of the world human
rights the right to live like a human
but these thoughts are expensive they're
going to cost us are we ready to pay the
price is America still a great idea as
well as a great country when I was a kid
in Dublin I watched in awe as America
put a man on the moon we thought you
know this is mad nothing is impossible
in America in America they can do
anything over there nothing was
impossible only human nature and it
followed because it was led is that
still true tell me it's true it's true
isn't it and if it isn't you of all
people can make it true again thank you
you very much it's the line